non
personne au monde ne peut faire à votre
place
ce que vous devez faire vous même alors
en général répondre à des questions qui
sont qui suis-je
où vais-je sont un petit peu longue à
mettre en place
l'ong dans la réflexion d'un individu et
en général c'est le genre de chose qui
commence à l'âge adulte alors l'âge
adulte commence par quoi
en général quand on commence à faire ses
études
quand on fait ses études on parle dans
une ambition très forte
on imagine la vision du métier qu'on
veut avoir un idéalisme la profession la
profession de rêve qu'on veut exercer
très bien on passe donc son baccalauréat
on part faire ses études
c'est parti pour un deux trois quatre
cinq ans où il y en a qui vont beaucoup
plus loin après chacun fait son fait son
petit bout de chemin et on se dit
surtout qu'on fera ce métier là jusqu'à
la fin de notre vie jusqu'à la retraite
alors après l'âge de la retraite dépend
évidemment du gouvernement dont vous
allez en passer par plusieurs durant
votre vie professionnelle
c'est comme ça c'est la vie on passe
différents diplômes beaucoup diplôme une
fois qu'on a passé pas mal de diplômes
en ce qui me concerne j'ai fait un dut
en publicité j'ai fait une école de pub
j'ai fait une école de commerce j'ai
fait une licence en histoire de l'art
j'ai fait une licence en lettres
bon y'a un moment donné je me suis dit
il va peut-être falloir s'arrêter
peut-être à l'effort travailler cache
pas que papa maman aussi monde il est
arrêté un moment donné il a bien fallu
que je plonge un moment donné dans la
vie professionnelle
et quand je vous parle de plonger ça a
été un plongeon j'ai un peu l'impression
que j'ai fait le grand saut genre record
du monde
les plongées à 15 mm sauf que 15 m ça
fait très haut quand vous tombez
je suis donc entré dans différentes
agences de communication ou
malheureusement toutes les espérances
que j'avais sur le métier
la vision les gens qui font qu'ils se
font ce milieu là ne correspondait
absolument pas à mes attentes
donc la vie professionnelle était au
début
sympathique puis un petit peu moins
encore un peu moins encore un peu moins
et bien et puis un jour et 20 ou burn
out
ah bon bah qu'est ce qu'on fait alors
dans ces cas là c'est un petit peu
compliqué on se pose des questions on se
dit qu'on a quand même passé pas mal de
diplômes qu'on a passé des années à
faire des études j'avais à ce moment-là
25 ans donc je vous cache pas que les
études plus 25 ans je me suis dit il me
reste a priori quelques années à vivre
sauf si je me fais écraser demain mais
ça c'est un autre problème qu'est ce que
je vais faire ma vie alors vous retombez
sept ans en arrière vous dites bon ok il
ya sept ans je voulais faire ça j'avais
une idéalisation du métier que je
voulais faire fiba en fait ça ne paie
pas enfin capricieuse on dirait
peut-être il s'avère qu'aujourd'hui j'ai
donc décidé de reprendre des études en
oui oui passer des diplômes je repars et
je repars sur quatre suspense du coup la
criminologie dire elle part de là elle
va d'abord elle se balade
oui elle se balade mais elle se balade
pourquoi parce qu'à un moment donné je
me suis aperçu que le milieu dans lequel
j'étais ne correspondait vraiment pas à
mes attentes et me pose est très souvent
des problèmes au quotidien de conscience
j'arrivais le matin devant la porte de
mon bureau j'avais envie de pleurer
à 25 ans un peu compliqué il ya d'autres
choses qui font plus rire 25 ans donc
c'est un peu dommage et là où c'était
très triste pour moi c'était j'avais
quelque part échoué
je me dis qu'au final c'est pas tant un
échec que ça aujourd'hui les études que
j'ai pu faire parce qu'elles elles m'ont
apporté des choses j'ai rencontré des
personnalités très intéressantes
d'autres beaucoup moins évidemment j'ai
été confronté aux ego de la pub je sais
pas si certains d'entre vous travaillez
la publicité et peuvent en témoigner
fred qui est passé tout à l'heure qui
était directeur marketing qui
aujourd'hui fait des motos je vous
laisse imaginer ce qui s'est aussi passé
dans sa tête à ce moment là alors quand
moi je suis arrivé sur marché de la pub
évidemment j'avais la possibilité
d'arriver sur un domaine qui était tout
nouveau qu'était le digital
c'était génial on pouvait faire des
multitudes de choses
c'étaient les champs d'action qu'on
avait été beaucoup plus large
il ya juste une information qu'on avait
oublié c'est que plus là je ne veux pas
dire meilleur
donc il faut beaucoup de force pour dire
stop
mais à un moment donné il faut aussi
apprendre à s'écouter et ne pas rester
cloisonné dans quelque chose qui ne vous
correspond pas donc lieu
d'épanouissement 0 dans mon métier je
fais autre chose criminologie je peux
vous expliquer pourquoi enfant je
voulais être médecin légiste ont fallait
faire médecine j'avais pas les capacités
donc j'ai autre chose donc la
criminologie aujourd'hui pour moi les
hyper intéressante pour plusieurs
raisons 1 parce que c'est un domaine qui
me passionne mais dans un deuxième temps
il faut pas y voir uniquement le sens
crime
on n'est pas uniquement sur des meurtres
non c'est pas que ça c'est pas que les
experts c'est pas qu esprits criminels
non aujourd'hui la criminologie c'est
tout ce qui ressemble tout ce qui
rassemble les sciences criminelles qui
vont être le délit vous avez pas payer
une amende qui vont être une infraction
qui vont être la délinquance qui vont
être le viol les agressions urbaine
toutes ces choses là qui moi aujourd'hui
me passionne d'aller comprendre pourquoi
l'être humain en est arrivé là
donc c'est ce que je vous disais la
criminologie ne ressent ne recense
pardon pas que que les crimes il ya
quelque chose qui est très important
dans la criminologie c'est qu'on
s'intéresse à l'individu qu'une chose
qu'on n'avait pas dans la communication
puisque on ne s'intéresse pas à
l'individu en lui-même on s'intéresse à
la population de masse on a des cibles
les 30-40 ans les jeunes les femmes les
hommes là on s'intéresse à l'individu en
lui-même à sa propre humanité
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui fait qu'un
individu est unique et sa robe ça
retombe sur trois piliers qui sont la
famille l'éducation et les rencontres
qui sont trois piliers indispensables
dans la vie de chacun et qui font ce que
vous êtes
aucun de ces piliers ne peut être a
priori moins important que l'autre une
personne équilibrée aura trois piliers
on va dire à 33 33% alors au même titre
qu'il n'y a pas de grands crimes sans
grands criminels bas c'était pareil dans
la pub y avait pas de grands marketeurs
sans grandes marques et le lien
aujourd'hui moi qui fait la force entre
la communication et la criminologie
c'est cette force d'aller confrontée la
communication en face de la criminal de
la criminologie sur différents moyens
que je vous présente juste ici qui sont
sur la criminologie on a un aspect qui
est très législatif très réglementée à
communication on et c'est l'éclaté
totale et c'est hyper créatif puis à
côté de ça la criminologie comme je vous
le disais s'intéresse à l'individualité
face à la communication qui elle
s'intéresse à la population de masse
alors ce qu'il faut que vous sachiez
c'est qu'on ne fait pas dans la vie des
études par hasard je suis désolé s'il ya
des étudiants aujourd'hui sur la salle
on taxe souvent les étudiants qui font
de la psycho de dire oui n'en est ce
qu'ils font psycho ils sont un peu barré
dans leur tête ils ont des problèmes
avec leurs parents leurs frères leurs
soeurs ont des problèmes à résoudre pour
qu'on attaque que ces gens là on a
choisi notre métier pour une raison bien
particulière
le problème c'est qu'on ne sait pas moi
j'avais choisi la communication parce
que ça avait l'air cool on pouvait
communiquer un message moi j'avais envie
d'aller communiquer des messages auprès
de plein de gens je trouve ça
fantastique en creusant un petit peu je
me suis rendu compte qu'en fait j'avais
moins à la base un problème de
communication
établir un contact est difficile
échanger avec les gens réussir à parler
un public qui arrive à voutré
aujourd'hui mais c'est compliqué les
années de communication non au final
permis d'essayer de résoudre ce problème
là et c'est comme quand vous faites une
psychanalyse une fois que vous avez fini
avec votre psy qu'analyste c'est plus
besoin d'aller le voir parce que les
problèmes sont résolus faire votre
propre métier aujourd'hui c'est la même
chose alors après avoir passé navan à
étudier cette population de masse dans
la communication entre mes études et mon
lieu professionnel
évidemment il fallait toujours qu'on
communique plus entre parenthèses pour
vendre plus et je me suis retrouvé
confronté à étudier tous ces gens mais
qui sont tous ces gens ces gens c'est
pas juste des gens c'est vous c'est vous
c'est vous c'est chaque individu sur
terre qui est différent on est 6
milliards et quelques sur la planète et
ben est similaire on est tous différents
et donc du coup c'est ce qui c'est ce
qui m'intéressait d'aller étudier
alors quand on change de voie
professionnelle parce que c'est ce que
j'ai fait et je suis jeune j'ai 26 ans
on vous l'expliquait jimmy je suis la
plus jeune de tous et aujourd'hui quand
on change de voir il faut jamais oublier
qu'on change sa voix intérieure
parce qu'au final aller découvrir qui
vous êtes dans vos différentes études
dans vos différentes formations va vous
permettre de vous élever spirituellement
à d'autres choses et d'aller chercher au
plus profond de vous même ce qui vous
intéressait le plus alors je vais vous
demander à tous on va faire juste un
petit test
fermez les yeux mettez votre main juste
en dessous au niveau de votre diaphragme
elle avoue dit mais qu'est ce qu'elle
fait est complètement folle peut-être
pas faux est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
tous la sensation de faire le métier que
vous auriez aimé faire est-ce qu'il ya
quelque chose qui résonne en vous
intérieurement et qui vous fait dire que
vous n'aviez pas forcément fait les
études forcément fait le métier que vous
voulez alors je vais pas vous interroger
tous un parent évidemment c'est pas de
but mais posez vous juste ces questions
et pour tous ceux qui éventuellement
aurait d'autres ambitions dans la vie
n'oubliez pas que il faut toujours
moindre doute et d'échouer que de perdre
si vous êtes et moi par exemple je suis
quelqu'un qui aime vivre pieds nus donc
je vais pour vous ce soir en vue de mes
chaussures sur scène bon je vends
d'enlever une ce sera plus simple
voilà merci à tous